star-lord has quickly risen to being one
of Marvel's most popular heroes thanks
to his role in guardians of the galaxy
but just a few years ago barely anyone
even comic book fans knew who he was
his newer fans might be surprised to
discover that he's kind of a galactic
jerk even though the Marvel Cinematic
Universe made him look more like Han
Solo than Boba Fett here's the dark side
of star-lord you never knew about he
brainwashed the Guardians the modern
guardians consist of some of the
universe's best warriors but also some
of its most notorious loners how did
quill convince everyone to join the team
he had another team member mantas
brainwash all of them to think it was a
good idea even worse he didn't even try
asking first he just went straight to
brainwashing forcing people to do
something they normally wouldn't do is
like the textbook definition of being a
villain so good job star-lord you creep
that time he rescued Thanos as the big
bad guy of the Marvel Universe
Thanos once killed half of all life not
just on earth but literally everywhere
simply because he could he also has a
crush on the female embodiment of death
not this one or this one but this one
everyone has a type
during Marvel's Thanos imperative story
star-lord and Nova sacrificed themselves
to help trap Thanos in another universe
because that's the heroic thing to do
but while Nova makes good on the
self-sacrifice star-lord finds a way out
and brings Thanos with him star Lords
truce with Thanos brings the universe's
worst villain back into action and that
just seems like another creepy villain
thing to do
he caused annihilation conquest in the
Marvel comic universe the first
annihilation war basically broke the
galaxy but it never would have happened
if it wasn't for star-lord he had
invited a group of space Knights to come
up date the Kree homeworld security
systems but the space Knights had
already been infected by the phallic s--
for those who don't know the phallic
Tsar basically Marvel's version of the
Borg and at the time they'd actually
been taken over by Ultron one thing
leads to another and the entire universe
is almost assimilated into the phallic
consciousness all because star-lord
thought the space Knights were cool
they aren't just look at this guy he's
like a heroic trashcan or something no
thanks he endangered earth earth it's
primitive and weak different alien
species are always trying to invade it
and the planet always just barely
survives that being the case it's not a
good idea to put the planet in extra
danger but star-lord didn't read the
memo in the comics his father the ruler
of the planet spartax basically puts a
target on the earth unless Peter returns
to the spartax Empire as a member of the
royal family that doesn't sound so bad
does it but of course in true star-lord
fashion he doesn't just immediately slip
into a life of royal intergalactic
luxury instead he puts all of his
friends and family in danger
to be fair Peters dad Jason isn't
exactly the nicest guy eventually
star-lord helps remove his father from
the throne but then he just leaves so it
surprises him when Spartak selects him
to be their next leader since he's the
heir to the throne and also the Empire's
big hero this should have been obvious
but instead of fulfilling his duties
quill tries to just abandon his people
that life of luxury must be a real heavy
burden and when he finally did take the
throne later on he did such a bad job
that his people outed him oh well he was
a lounge singer when all of reality
crashes together during Marvel's Secret
Wars a small contingent of heroes
survived the end of the world on a
lifeboat built by Reed Richards when
they land on the patchwork planet of
battleworld star-lord finds himself in
an alternate version of Manhattan
instead of getting back into the hero
game he works as a lounge singer until
he meets up with an alternate version of
Kitty Pryde he finds his way back to the
resistance to help lead the charge
against God doom the ruler of battle
world but he'd probably still be singing
if he never run into an actual hero
speaking of which he's insanely jealous
Peter quill and Kitty Pryde were the it
couple of the Marvel Comics universe for
a bit but their relationship took a turn
for the worst when star-lord decided to
step up and become the leader of spartax
prompting Kitty to take up his old
mantle as the new star-lord Peter didn't
like having another more effective
star-lord kicking around the galaxy and
the two
had a fairly messy breakup before
reconciling maturity has never been one
of quills strong suits what are you
doing I'm distracting you big turd
blossom thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to